it is game two of the nlds from
wisconsin it's the braves and the
brewers ready to go branded woodruff on
the hill for the brewers oh another big
arm the brewers are throwing out this
braves team three career starts against
atlanta 1-1 with the 2-7
like burns yesterday big fastball good
curve ball 2-2
in the air to right field garcia
wandering in
is under
and makes the catch for out number one
freeman finished the regular year and
even 300.
dropping in and freeman will take the
walk a one out based on balls that's a
one-out walk to freddie freeman his
third walk in the series well now one on
aussie albies that's out of the free
spot finish the year with 30 home runs
106 runs batted in
it's a fly ball
towards foul ground long run and over to
make the catch
thomas the shortstop
all the way over to the tarp area looked
like he had no chance throws the glove
out makes the grab some kind of play by
william thomas in foul ground
he reached out made a big move
snatched it
and held on
what a catch
what a play by william thomas
woodruff deals again
[Applause]
up and in with a fastball at 97.
and what a season for max nl pitcher of
the month in september and his final
month saw him put up 41 innings where he
walked just seven struck out 36 and
allowed just 23 base hits
to center and duvall back to step for
two handles out number one
swinging a miss and adonis strikes out
first k of the day for max free two down
his fastball plays up
97 even 98 guys and he just sneaks it
right by him switch hitter
swings to the first pitch and a roller
out to dansby he gloves it cleanly wings
it across to freddy and that's a three
up three down bottom of the first inning
two down with rosario it's second base
here comes dansby swanson here it is
bouncer hit to short
and
in plenty of time willian thomas
throws him out
on an easy bouncer hit by dansby swanson
oh one fish to show there hit hard down
the left field line of base hit this one
rattles the wall takes a brewer kick out
to yelich he fires to second here's so
larry he slides in safe with a double
jorge solaire in scoring position with
one down for the atlanta braves woodruff
trying to go in misses out over the
plate man in scoring position
freeman lines one to right field for a
big hit jorge solaire being waved around
here comes the throw from garcia's got a
great arm but it'll be late
and the braves strike first as solaire
comes in on the freddie freeman they sit
to right one-nothing atlanta ami garcia
able to get to that baseball quickly it
was hit hard by freddie freeman
and obvious throw one hopper but it
checked a bit on the grass
fouled out to william
shortstop and they go one
hit to right very well back garcia still
back warning track looks up it is off
the top of the fence and stays in play
garcia fires in wong's got it there's
going to be a play at the plate wong
throws home pina can't handle it it's
two-nothing atlanta
it hit right off the top of the fence
that bullet by aussie albies garcia got
it in quickly to colton wong
but wong for whatever reason held the
baseball for just a beat
and because of that
it allowed freddie freeman to come in
and score off pitch to solaire with one
out
and that's a strikeout back-to-back case
for woodruff six at all and that's the
gas there at 98. two down for freddy
freeman woodruff coming back freeman
lines one to a leaping stab by colton
wong
to end the inning
he took a main set away from freddie
freeman
with a leaping grab
to his left to pull that one down two
down in the fifth for manny pena
freed kicks and fires strike three
curveball falls right off the table
swung on and missed by pedia and that's
now seven strikeouts for freed who has
pieced together five shutout innings
here in game two
elevates and all these chases and
strikes out seven k's for woodruff that
fastball four seen
up in the zone nine in a row now retired
by woodruff one out in the sixth inning
for austin reilly
speaking of right center gap this is
headed out towards right center field
deep bar and that ball is gone
kept on going austin reilly
with his 34th home run of the year 33
during the regular season and he takes
it out to right center field on cue and
the atlanta braves jump out on top three
to nothing that is a big one and you
knew he got it when kane stopped running
it was the change up but he couldn't get
it inside this time it was on the outer
third gives this brave team a three
nothing lead
thomas spouting with two down bases
empty here in the sixth inning so far
only two hits put together
by the milwaukee brewers here's a liner
to right field solaire going back going
to be over his head one hops the wall
thomas is headed for two he'll get there
with a slide and a double with two down
here in the sixth inning it's a line
shot quickly over the head of solaire in
right field here's the 2-2 from free
got him swinging strike three
and he once again silences the brewers
two strikeouts in the inning no runs one
hit no errors and one man left
six shutout innings for max freed
and just like that the tying runs coming
to the plate for the brewers here in the
seventh inning
brings it
swung on and missed that is strike three
and it took four strikes but now the
braves are walking off the field
so that ends the bottom of the seventh
and the brewers train runners at first
and second no runs one in
from the stretch the pitch
swinging pop fly
playable luis ureas foul territory
right alongside the frames dugout makes
the catch
and the inning is over
brains get nothing they strand two first
and second with one out eduardo escobar
everyone's swinging those gold towels
escobar to right field solaire is there
and he makes the catch
tagging at second heading for third is
peterson the throw will go to second and
he is easily to third the batter is
abbasil garcia he's one for three in
this ball game pitch on the way
a lunge and a miss for strike three
another huge swing and a miss and again
the brewers leave men on base
again they are denied a right-handed
batter runners at first and second the
first pitch on the way to melee ground
ball out to third reilly to ozzy for one
ozzy the first double play
and the braves are heading back to
atlanta with the series even want a
piece
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes